For anyone out there who enjoys
working from home in their softest sweatpants.
Anyone like to do that?
Some of us had some time at home.
(audience cheering)
In some industries they're like,
"You gotta come back to the office."
People are not giving up their sweatpants,
and now science is behind you.
They say your sweats make you better
at your job actually.
What?
Yeah.
(audience clapping)
"The Wall Street Journal" reports a study tested
hundreds of people working at home on Zoom.
They had some dress up in like formal business attire
and others were just in their casual comfies.
And the results are in,
the comfy group was the most engaged
and immersed in their tasks.
They felt the most authentic,
allowing them to feel very present in their work.
Drew, are you gonna be elastic head-to-toe from now on?
I'm a little surprised
by this.
Yeah, me too, honestly.
And as a sweat pant enthusiast,
I am surprised by this.
Because I do kind of believe
in that whole like dress the part thing.
And every time I wanna wear my sweats like on a date,
my friend's gasp as if, you know,
it's the most horrible idea
on the planet.
It is.
It is the most horrible idea.
Well, I'm like,
"You might as well know
where this is all ending up right now."
But I am surprised by this.
Where do we go from here?
Every big designer is now making athleisure.
I walked by a Gucci, it was all sweatpants head-to-toe.
So maybe you've started a trend, Drew.
No, I think I've just thrown the towel in
and everybody else is doing it too.
They've joined in, yeah.
All right, and finally, we've got a beautiful moment
from Oak Hill Elementary School in Georgia.
The head custodian there, Lana Gazhenko,
is a Ukrainian with a family living back home in Ukraine.
And "USA Today" reports that the students at the school
wanted to show her that they were thinking about Ms. Lana.
So they put up this surprise art project,
and it's dozens of hand-drawn sunflowers,
the national flower of Ukraine,
and messages hoping for peace and safety
for Ms. Lana's family and all of Ukraine.
Aw!
I know.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think that needs any words.
(upbeat music)